so how do you feel that your
vulnerability is hoping so many people
that also struggle with Tourette's get
through and do you feel any pressure to
continue going because you're like kind
of like the face of it no I don't give a
those guys and
no I'm joking it's been it's lovely it's
really nice people like reach out and
stuff because I never expected it to
when I told people I had Tourette's it
was a very selfish thing I was doing to
be like
I'm giving everybody a heads up here at
twitch sometimes don't make a big deal
out of it I was not doing it in like a
sort of
I need to open up and be brave and let
people know that wasn't but I'm a I'm a
deeply selfish person and I don't think
about others at all but um I just said
it and it was like all these people came
in and were like oh I really appreciate
it my son's got tourettes he's like
seven he's struggling at the minute and
he has like he sees you doing your job
and he wants to be like a footballer
[Music]
and he wants to do that and he's worried
that his techs will hold him back Etc
but he sees you doing your job and um
and doing well at it and I guess that
does make you feel not a sense of
responsibility because again as I said
selfish person I'm number one in my life
but I would feel as genuinely nice even
from again being selfish it's nice to
know I'm I'm not the only one I like to
know that I'm not
um special in my suffering do you know
what I mean yeah which is an odd way to
phrase it like
we all go through
and I am not the only one to be like it
helps me not be like what was me my life
so hard and all the rest of it because
I've got it easy yeah so I mean but I do
like that it gives people hope it does
give people hope you know what I mean so
it's like for the kids I may be
struggling with tourettes it does give
them that hope that they can achieve
those of course because that's the thing
Mal I could if I was really having an
awful boat of Tourette's today before I
came and done this interview and we're
doing this little giglier I thought it
was really really really really
struggling with it I could I could form
my two miles and be like I can't do this
I'm in such a bad way
but these kids have to go to school you
can't just like phone up and be like I'm
not going to come in blah blah you have
to like live your life as like a young
kid I'm in a very privileged position I
mean in a number of ways but like
just as far as Teresa is concerned with
I can I have the luxury of not being
able to do things if I'm having a really
bad day I mean but that's the thing
I sort of take away from it is how hard
it must be for people who aren't in that
position yeah I want to jump to one
thing I hear that you do you live with
your best friend and his girlfriend I do
well is that is that the I heard I moved
over one of my best friends Niall Cox
his name is okay it's an unfortunate
last name
um but it's apt let me tell you that
um but he yes and he now his girlfriend
as slowly she just got back from like a
Year's traveling
he stayed with her for a year that's
mental true love though long distance
true love though I would never do it but
they never saw each other for that year
oh okay that's mental that's widowed but
a fair play of the Naomi and nail
um but she is now that she's back so she
started just slowly creeping she's kind
of there a lot and then all of a sudden
I we've agreed upon a rent
price I guess okay because enough is
enough this is my roof yeah and you guys
are taking me for a ride here are you a
good roommate
are you do you know what my flatmate now
he's kind of like
handsome quite well-kept you've got like
a yeah thank you yeah like me yeah thank
you I appreciate you doing that but he's
got a car he's got like a nice like
beard that's all like Trend paper for
these Hills because he's quite like
ripped
you would think he's I'm the messy one
if you had to look at us because I look
a bit
like a baggage sometimes right and
that's okay we can see that I've not
dressed up for this unfortunately which
I apologize thank you yeah that's who I
am yeah but I'm cleaner than him for
sure we have an air fryer do you have
airfryer yes he does not clean that bag
ever he hasn't cleaned the Thing Once
why do people not think they have to
clean the air fryer oh it drives me
cats you gotta soak it for like at least
a Day
Scrub the thing
and this is I put tin foil in there and
the wash dishes and he goes in
he goes in there bear bear back bear
back
and it doesn't clean it
um you talk in the documentary a lot
about the pressure surrounding this
album you know you say you have your
whole life to write your first one and
you just have about a year to write the
second one yeah
how do you feel what's the message
behind this album
man I don't know a bunch of just a bunch
of yeah no no no
it's just it's an album I can't stop I'm
talking a lot more about myself in this
album I think um in the past it's been
about relationships and
um sort of
um you know like other people with this
one's really sort of looking inwards a
bit more I think and I think uh that
like the song how I'm feeling now that
came out alongside the documentary is
very much about my mental health and
how I feel I haven't been flossed into
this sort of job
um and there's I guess there's a lot
more about me and my sort of
um it's not just all relationships and
love for not rest of it there's quite a
lot of them
I guess
introspective that's a word that's the
word I already knew it but you seem to
be good with words because how do you
how do you name these albums okay
because they sound like they're so
eloquent you know you have uh divinely
uninspired to a hellish extent yeah and
broken by desire to be Heavenly Sent
well remembered row remember yeah yeah
you know it's wordy it's worthy how do
you come up with these album titles so
basically I have a song called figure
out that hasn't been released it was
supposed to be the first song on my
first album and then it was supposed to
be the first song on my second album and
I still haven't got around to finishing
it so I just took it took those two
lines of the foot the song starts off by
saying
um broken bird is there to be heavily
said divinely honest extent so it's like
there we go so hopefully it'll be on the
third album because if not I think the
people who are called the song are going
to sue me
because I have really been dining out on
that song yeah without them seeing any
Financial reward from it me Rick and
these guys
they're both they're both but um but
yeah no I want to make it the first song
in the third album and that'll be like
the sort of okay
I like it yeah I like it conniving
calculated
and just see how many times I can see
that work to do without people yeah yeah
the three C's yeah so okay so we're also
talking about a story uh that came out
you well in the documentary you can find
it in Ed Sheeran you told them about
your imposter syndrome that you're
experiencing and he happened to Spill
the Beans to Elton John yeah you
received a letter were you more happy to
receive that letter or were you pissed
that Ed Sheeran was talking about your
stuff to other people me and Ed got in a
fist fight after that yeah it was the
most feeble fight no I'm joking we no I
was I was famous I actually really was
uh
quite touched by it I'm not someone
who's overly sentimental or overly
emotional
if you've watched the film you probably
know that I don't cry once come on must
be the first
documentary music documentary and
there's a lot of them yeah too many if
you ask me including mine
um that people I don't think anyone's
not cried
and then yeah I made a story when
is the win that's it yes of course but
um but no it really meant a lot to me
that the Ed would think
to even the fact that Ed Sheeran and
Elton John are having a conversation and
about me when I'm not in the vicinity
blows my mind it's just like through the
biggest singers of all time that's a
pinch me as a pinch mean and then yeah
and he reached about it just it means a
lot and I think that's the thing having
since spent some time with him
crying
um I feel like
yeah it's interesting every time I'm
with him or I've hung out with them it's
only been like a handful of times he's
always asking about how I'm doing as
opposed to you know how my songs are
doing it's never about like the sort of
business you say the things always like
how are you doing because I guess he's
been through it all and seen it all and
done it all
tenfolds you know what I mean so and
yeah he's very it's very nice I wish he
would stop being Milton yeah it's like
come on in yeah
pretty cool
okay so we see your friend now in the uh
in the dark you know and I want to show
you something because we sat down with
Nile um recently and he told us about
you know driving across the country with
you and doing your thing and we asked
them what the pros were and what the
cons were right and this is what he said
about the cons okay so you gotta tell me
I'd say the worst thing is um
the constant farting
and and uh I thought I could swear I
thought I was a cursor you know I swear
like a sailor but um Capaldi's got a
one-up on me on that one for sure
every SEC every second word is a Beat is
that accurate
we've been doing this interview for five
minutes
I don't know if you've been farting over
there but no no I've been I've been
sucking my farts then don't you worry
um when I got out here I'm gonna let
lifts though don't you trust me
um but no yeah if he is
a piece of dream to travel with I would
say that
um but he's quite right I can't I
wouldn't um I'll hold my hands up yeah
sometimes I'd be farting sometimes you
do sometimes I'll be passing okay last
time we sat down with you uh you talked
to us about being on Tinder gold yes are
you still in the swiping business are
you are you wifed up are you I'm wafed
up your wife up now because I saw
something about not wiped up a
girlfriend yeah your girlfriend
okay uh yes she is a lady she is just
about I think I'll have to double check
she's going to be moving in with uh with
uh can you imagine that Naomi does it
start with a bad second but no she will
not be moving in with us okay because I
um I think I'm holding on to my youth a
bit too much so she's a bet yeah never
mind she's over she's the only act two
she doesn't see that she was two years
younger than me it's nothing weird I
just said the way I said that was like
she was in school but like also you know
she's doing a sort of a levels and she's
kind of working at that anyway but
um
yes
yes okay
and I hope I still have one after this
okay I hope so too okay yeah